What the...?
I see. You're the assassin, aren't you?
Dodged!
You asshole!
So, your target must be Tokita!
He used Tokita's leg to jump up on him?
This jerk is...
You have some nerve.
It's Ohma's turn to attack.
Ground grappling techniques?
It's not a bad idea.
But unfortunately, you're too light.
He stopped at the last moment!
I'd have landed that blow
if I hadn't noticed. You brat.
A girl?
You can't mask your gender.
I could tell by your scent.
What the hell do you want?
I want to have a baby with you.
What?
I knew you were strong
as soon as I saw you.
I'm Karura. Be my husband.
That's, um...
-A marriage proposal?
-Why is she asking him now?
My grandpa told me
that it's the responsibility of the head
of the family to have strong offspring.
-Excuse me, miss. Could you explain--
-Let's make babies together!
Hello, are you ignoring me?
They were all very confused
by her sudden and baffling
marriage proposal.
But the one who felt most confused was...
this man.
Babies? Husband?
Me? With this girl?
What the hell is she talking about?
Wow, even Ohma is shocked,
and he's usually so cool!
Come on, let's make some babies together!
Children that are yours and mine!
Our children will undoubtedly
become the greatest ever warriors!
Let's get married right now!